new details emerging after the fbi
stormed the private home of former
president donald trump the raid
reportedly over an investigation into
classified documents right a source says
agents looked at every single office
safe and grabbed documents and boxes and
they were not being judicious about what
they took we are also learning that
trump's team voluntarily turned over 15
boxes to the government way back in
january and the former president's
lawyers had a meeting with investigators
in june over the issue but they still
decided to raid his place anyway trump
coming out swinging over what happened
saying quote it's a prosecutorial
misconduct
the weaponization of the justice system
and an attack by radical left democrats
who desperately don't want me to run for
president in 2024
republicans warning the doj and a.g
garland they better be ready to explain
themselves or face the consequences
what was on the war what were you really
doing what were you looking for why not
talk to president trump and have him
give the information you're after we now
find that justice in america is not
equal it's determined upon whether you
want to go after a political a person or
not and you go after your political foes
i think that's wrong the fbi when it
comes to trump has lost their way
this
unending desire to destroy trump and his
family
is frustrating
and the white house doesn't want to talk
about it
is this administration weaponizing the
justice department and the fbi against
political opponents
peter the president believes in the rule
of law
the president believes in the
independence of the department of
justice
no that is no it's a yes a no for you
i'm answering the question
you may not like it but i'm answering
the question and i'm no no i'm answering
the question and i'm telling you that we
are not going to comment
on a criminal investigation
judge when i was reading that and came
up upon that part about classified
documents i heard you utter a
two-syllable word that began with b
and ended with t
care to explain how you feel about this
i did not over those words you know what
are those words harold my friend to the
left
i get accused of everything and no one
wants to take accountability
all right let me let me tell you what i
think
what happened to donald trump last night
was a continuing example of the left's
attempt for the last seven years to take
this man down
that search warrant and the subsequent
execution of that warrant was nothing
more than a subterfuge a fix fishing
expedition to get whatever they can
against this man because in seven years
i have not been able to get anything
against him we've got a politicized
justice department a politicized fbi all
i have to tell you is we've got a
department of justice and an fbi that is
willing to sick the fbi on parents as
domestic terrorists we now have the irs
about to sick 87 000 irs agents against
the rest of us this is classic overreach
but let me tell you about donald trump
you had a search warrant on presidential
records are you kidding me classified
records that he could unilaterally
declassify when he was president he
could say he declassified them and you
come in i was a judge if you came to me
and you said you wanted a search horn my
first question is why do you want a
search warrant why not a subpoena and if
i had all the facts i would know that
this president had been working with
them and had already given them 15 boxes
that the media kept saying they were
retrieved but you know what the national
association of records uh
archives national archives records
administration wrote a letter saying we
obtained the cooperation of trump
representatives to locate records not
transferred to the national archives
they admitted
when they kept saying the media kept
saying oh trump didn't want to give him
the records trump said hey look one
working with you they gave him a letter
saying yeah he was cooperating with us
yeah so now now what they want to do is
they the fbi that lied to the fisa
judges the fbi that had an affidavit for
a warrant that contained a
lie by christopher steele who hated
donald trump a dossier that was false
they get these judges to sign the
warrants this is the same fbi the same
doj that comes out and doesn't prosecute
any wrongdoing they want to prosecute
donald trump for what for an
administrative error well that's the
thing so assuming it's an error and i'm
not willing to admit it well the thing
is i mean what what the judge is sitting
on is what uh you had andy mccarthy on
your show to talk about perhaps the
motive it has nothing to do with the
documents at all but trying to link
they're trying to pressure the doj to
find evidence linking some kind of
criminal activity on january 6th
to donald trump yeah so think about the
pressure on merrick garland right um
he's being
accused essentially by people on the
left of not being tough enough if not
posting a project pushing a prosecution
here they've got a grand jury that is
underway right now that's looking at a
potential role in incitement of
insurrection and uh the stopping of a
certification of the electoral college
so that that's going on over here on
this side right
and then you have this raid that is
ostensibly about this issue of
preserving presidential records uh but
andy mccarthy came on today and wrote a
really good piece today that's in the
new york post that you can read uh where
he basically said look they're casting a
wide net exactly what janine is saying
they're looking uh to fish through all
of these documents and see if they can
find anything that can help them in this
in this uh larger picture of what
they're working on with this grand jury
because they're under a lot of pressure
to come up with something uh to con to
get him not to run again in 2024. but
you know one of the things the thing
that kept striking me last night as i
was watching the videos of these
flashing lights outside the house right
and i spoke to a former federal
prosecutor this morning who said you
know the the
over
you know demonstration of people and
cars and flashing lights in front of the
house uh they didn't need to go in there
with that kind of force and that kind of
drama and theater if they didn't get
this right
this will be the biggest boondoggle in
law enforcement history it will do
nothing but inspire this former
president to run again and probably fire
up his supporters in a way let me think
about it think about the way roger stone
was brought in think about peter navarro
think about all of the history here
think about you know my mind goes back
to james comey going in in the early
stages while they were in the transition
with michael flynn and saying and you
know what he said you know just send
some guys over there they're not really
with it yet they don't really know how
this works we're just send some agents
over and see what you can get out of
michael flynn before they really figure
out how this all works it goes all the
way back to that this story so they
better have it they better have it
nailed down airtight or it's going to
blow up in their faces but you do point
out there is a pattern to this so it it
normally you should be able to trust the
fbi but not in the last 10 years
it's kind of over but then you look at
the fact that trump is like an energy
energy monster they're just feeding him
this is going to make him run this is
going to like
do you think that they've caused the
opposite reaction i've never seen the
base more energized i've never seen the
base more angry i'm angry i feel
violated the whole country feels
violated it's disgusting they've
declared war on us and now it's game on
imagine you're eric trump and you're at
mar-a-lago that's your home your mother
has just died two weeks ago and they're
sending fbi agents with weapons into
your house violating your privacy like
that it's unbelievable
over the presidential records act greg
that's like a librarian sending armed
agents into your house
the presidential records act
first of all we can't even trust that
this warrant wasn't corrupt i mean they
cooked up a fake warrant last time when
they spot on the trump campaign they
doctored evidence they forged documents
to get it how do we know they're not
planning evidence right now they planted
evidence with crooked and the cia and
the fbi already
and you can't trust this judge they said
oh a judge must have signed off on it
the judge is an obama donor the judge
defended jeffrey epstein's team you
can't trust this guy so they go in
they'll probably do a fishing expedition
god knows what they're going to find or
plant or fake but it's also trying to
freeze the trump base you know you're
going to vote for this guy
you know he could be indicted soon it's
telling the republican donors hey don't
donate to this guy republican corporate
guys don't donate to this guy he's toxic
you don't want to go near him that's
what's going on it's intimidation it's
bullying look at this thing he did he
was cooperating so he's about
almost nine months of cooperation he's
already handed over about 15 boxes as
janine said she's right he could have
declassified this before he left the
white house so they get in they bring
teams in already they're showing them
where his stuff is they're showing them
where they keep it the team says all
right keep it secure keep it locked up
trump's lawyers were trump even stopped
in and swung by and said hello next
thing you know they send 30 men
with a safe cracker
what the hell are they doing and they
told the trump lawyers don't look at
what we're doing don't record what
they're doing that's not by the book no
and if you look at what hillary's done i
mean she's acid washed 30 000 emails
under subpoena hillary's own lawyers
smashed iphones with hammers and comey
comes out and he says yes
they had over a hundred classified
documents in her possession in chappaqua
and yes they did break the law but no
prosecutor would ever touch it and then
sandy burglar goes into the national
archives and sets all kinds of
classified documents down his pants they
didn't raid his home
two cia directors had classified
information on their home computers
their homes weren't raided an fbi
director took sensitive documents
outside they didn't raid his home this
is bull and it's going to boomerang big
time everybody can feel it so harold uh
you've heard 10 minutes of uh
commentary what do you
what strikes you about this this is a
it's obviously
a very serious thing that went on last
night and it's affected a lot of people
right is this probably probably that the
president even even more so the former
president
i look at this
um with a great deal of sympathy for
someone who's been accused of something
it looks as if the president
may be accused of something now the
judge and all of us know you're innocent
until proven otherwise in our country
and the president and everyone is
entitled to that and that presumption of
innocent stance but here's what i can't
get my my arms around listening to all
of this there's no doubt this is
unprecedented historic if the justice
department has bungled this this will be
a colossal catastrophic i'm 52 years old
it'll be hard to reclaim credibility in
my adult life so they have that risk on
them too this is a court
approved
warrant
now if a court approved the search
warrant for my home
and they came in a nut search warrant
said we believe you have 10 kilos of
cocaine
10 ak-47s three documents showing you're
going to work with russia two documents
with china to betray our country
i turn that warrant right over to you
greg i'll turn over to you judge i turn
it but you martha you jesse and every
other show here at fox and i'd ask
suzanne scott let me turn over to cnn
also because i'd want everyone to know
i'm innocent i have no clue
why they would come to my home why they
thought they would find this and you
should ask them if they found it
i hear what everybody's saying this is a
great political strategy you guys have
articulated in fact if i ever get in
trouble i want you all to articulate one
for me
what it's not is a legal strategy
because the legal strategy would be and
judge i would ask you this question in
just about 30 seconds more i have here
if you were advising put aside president
clinton any client that had this
happened to them
would you not say
that search warrant enumerates what they
were coming here to look for let's
release that to the press and if we
believe there was something wrong doing
here and you were my lawyer judge i'd
have you march me right in the federal
court this morning to say that this was
illegal they had no right to do this and
i want the world to know that not only
am i innocent i have no clue what these
people were looking for now the
speculation about what this is about
january 6
georgia new york some classified
documents i have no clue i've read all
the reporting i saw some reporting last
week that said that there was this awful
story this 10 year old little girl
that was raped and was an incest case
and he had attorney generals across the
country including in those two states
said we don't know what this case is
about we think the democrats have made
it all up only to have to come back and
recant
to find out when the facts came out i
think we should wait for the facts to
come out here uh the president is
presumed innocent
until proven otherwise and i agree with
that but your speculation i just think
is just i don't think it's speculation
at all you do not you do not break into
a house
of a guy that you've been working with
for nine months that you have to admit
has been cooperating with you for
presidential records no can i ask you a
question no i'm going to answer your
questions
and you do not do that and have guys
with ar-15 and women i might add at the
front of mar-a-lago and in a situation
like this where the man's about to
announce for president if he's going to
run for president but if i were the
lawyer the first thing i'd say is as a
citizen of the united states i want to
know from the department of justice why
you're doing this i want to know from
the fbi whether or not this is
legitimate because everything that
you've done regarding donald trump has
been illegal illegitimate and immoral
and the country knows it and you have
destroyed our faith in the justice
system just one question judge doug and
it's not donald trump's fault it's their
fault his lawyers have that search
warrant they could release it the
government can answer the question
that was a great a block you're welcome
[Applause]
everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want you
to do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now